Hey, welcome back. So, I'm going to do
more of a thorough guide on how to do
the Infiniti QX60. It's a 2016 and this
is going to apply for like the the 14
through 19 Prox buttons. Uh if you have
other questions about the Infinities,
check out the links below. But let's get
started. So, we want to be super
thorough. So, we have key one, key2, our
smart pro. Let's make sure the vehicle
starts. So, we turn it on. Great. Let's
make sure that sensor works. Not just
trust the proximity, but let's make sure
the key works with that sensor as a dead
battery test. So, I open up the working
key and I'm going to leave it here and
I'm going to brake pedal. Push button
and it'll say no key detected. Great.
Now, I'm going to brake pedal in
and it starts up. Good. Let's go ahead
and turn it off. Put it there. Double
check. Doesn't turn on. And let's double
check again.
Great. So now we know the proximity
works, the buttons work, the sensor
works. Let's go ahead and start the
programming process. The reason why that
sensor doesn't work, you delete the
keys, you can't add them back in, and
you are stranded with a bricked vehicle.
Now it's back and assembled. We have one
working key and one non-programmed key.
Let's go and get started. So, we're
looking at QX60 14 through 19.
We're going to connect
switch off hazards on.
Go to program keys.
Use the lock button.
And we have key one, key two, three, and
four. If we had multiple keys,
this where it deletes everything.
Good. Let's check.
Cool. It turns on. Good. And now it's
checking the proximity.
Okay. And we turn off.
Okay.
of the first prox one.
And I'm going to good angle like this.
And I'm not holding the buttons. I'm
going to hold like this. One. Two.
And you see it flash. Great.
And I keep it there. I'm going to pull
away. It flashed. I'm going to turn off.
Okay. Put it back. You want to program
more keys? Yes.
of the next procs. This one. Same thing.
One, two.
You see it flash five times. Great.
Okay.
Off.
Do you want to program more keys? No.
Of key one. Key one.
And I'm going to press one, two.
That audible beep means it's finished.
Complete. Good.
And
cool.
Nice.
Cool.
Trunk is open. Cool. Now we're just
going to cut the key and then we're good
to go. Other than that, thanks for
watching and I will see you next time.
See you. Bye.
[Applause]
[Music]
out.
[Applause]
Let's check the key inserts. So, we have
the original key. It's kind of dirty.
Smooth. Let's switch to the new key.
Smooth. Same turn factor, so it's all
good. And just like that, we're all
done. Make sure you check out the
channel, like, comment, subscribe.
Thanks.